there's like throw out my phone I don't
need you anymore just kidding I like
desperately still need you this week we
are trying to detach ourselves from our
phones using wearable technology my
personal struggle is the anxiety of like
causally checking for messages from
certain individuals when I try to curb
the mindlessness of just like opening my
phone and swiping through I'm on my
phone before I go to sleep when I wake
up at work with my friends I'm just
always on my phone didn't even think
about it I just opened my phone and like
went to my email I like sometimes see
myself like missing parts of
conversation it is connecting me with
all these other people and not
connecting me with the first nut sitting
right next to me to track how much I use
my phone we downloaded the moment app
yesterday I use my phone for five hours
and 23 minutes five hours three hours
and 11 minutes that's really scary
[Music]
listen very like stylish I'll set it for
boys I'm tech statement so probably one
for my mom and my dad to be my mother if
she calls now that I'm saying that out
loud I don't need to be checking my
phone call that off huh
I'm hoping that this ring will like kind
of serve as likely you tie something
around your finger to not forget
three and a half hours of my life I want
that time back just set up my Ringley
and it's already annoying me because
it's just vibrating all I'm just trying
to get work done I don't need to know
what my mom texted me asking like what
Tanya from high school is up to you it's
been cool feeling all the notifications
but then I'll absolutely check when
they're happening moment app takes up a
lot of battery space so I'm actually
using my phone less because my phone's
dying I just got home from work and
they've been on my phone for 45 minutes
I didn't even realize it I'm a failure
but my phone has made me aware of like
me waking up and checking my email and
text messages right away so about the
doctors that I'm really bored I thought
would be today because anything that I
gonna be a my phone so I got to make
Joey Aiden that's kind of helping only
been on for about two hours and it's now
currently around 3:00 p.m. in the
afternoon so I think that's already a
lot less than what I've been using the
ringleaders it helped me from wanting to
scroll through my phone while I'm
watching TV and it reminds me of the
text messages that I'm getting while I'm
watching TV so it's not super helpful
with that numbers for my phone I have
only gone down like 30 minutes right now
the ring we was awesome in a meeting
today because I've Google Calendar
alerts set up and it buzzed when it was
15 minutes towards the end of the hour
as I knew it was time to sort of get
things going and finish up and it was a
great moment without having to look at
my phones so I'm laying in bed all I
want to do is check Instagram but I
can't be on my phone right now so I'm
gonna just try to go to sleep but I'm
just constantly thinking you know what
is happening on Instagram I'm sorry
right now this feels like I'm being like
nannied by an app on my phone
it's just Thursday and I just woke up
and I just looked at my phone to see
what my numbers were yesterday and I
guess on Wednesday I went down from
three hours to like two and a half hours
which isn't great but I'm making
progress
so I'm sitting outside and I haven't
picked up my phone once there's the sky
and I'm like try not to text and I'm try
not to be anxious but whatever and it's
a much better method of not looking at
your phone like this is the first time
I've looked at my phone and like maybe
five hours all day listen to the market
and it took me like half the time
because I wasn't checking text messages
the whole time I sit outside and talk to
anyone if you really want to stop
looking at your phone and find yourself
someone to crush on or the week's over
and I feel like now I have a much more
healthy relationship with my phone than
I did before
I went from being on my phone for five
hours to being on my phone for an hour
and fifty minutes three hours and 40
minutes one hour and fifteen minutes a
day
I've never stayed off my phone for that
long it's so light free set of snap
chatting on my commute I was actually
taking in the city and talking with my
friends more hanging out my roommate
more it gave me a whole new sense of the
life I'm pissing outside of my phone
probably just tied a string around my
finger and called it a day
I would recommend just the actual
intentional motivation to just curb your
phone usage rather than relying on a
piece of technology what am I gonna do
with all that time now
maybe I'll take up knitting
[Music]